So now, it's time to see if you can define a daysBetweenDates procedure that
will produce the approximately correct results using the current nextDay
procedure. If we add a correct nextDay procedure, your daysBetweenDates should
produce exactly correct results. And I'm going to suggest one thing is a hint.
Doing daysBetweenDates by itself is still going to be more complicated than we
want one procedure to be. So, I'm going to encourage you to start by defining a
helper procedure. And if you're following the problem solving strategy we've set
out so far, you should test the helper procedure independently before you try to
build the complete daysBetweenDates procedure. But I'm going to leave it up to
you to figure out what would be a useful helper procedure and how to do this.